[Music]
there's rumors you you would like to do
Dancing with the Stars after this is
that true it would be fun you know who
wouldn't want to do it uh yes if they
were to focus on being The Bachelor um
if they asked i mean i don't think i
would say my first thought wouldn't be
no but i think anyone feel lucky to even
be considered and would you go the
hollywood route would you there's rumors
out there that you would mind wouldn't
mind doing some acting well i mean
before i was asked me the bachelor I had
been living in LA and I've done some
stuff in this kind of treatment world I
also lucky enough to have my own
business my focus more than anything is
that business from a professional
standpoint mm-hmm and if I am lucky
enough to do some other things and great
but right now that's not something I'm
actively anything I got to be open to
any great opportunity you know I never
thought I'd go back on paradise or the
Bachelorette and or the bachelor but I
think I've learned in life that it's
best to sit back and let things come
away and take each situation on its own
you